so it seems to me that technology that
is brought by science and the way in
which that technology is organized and
applied is the central force that is
that drives that drives history and that
has both a scientific and a
technological dimension and it also has
the social scientific dimension the
domain of economics the domain of
politics the domain of sociology of how
society organizes itself as all of this
changes and I emphasize the importance
of this in part not to say that human
nature doesn't in a profound way shape
history not to say that the forces of
jealousy and anger and love and greed
and the stuff of Greek tragedy aren't
central in shaping history but they are
relatively constant it seems to me the
range of human emotion the response to
provocation of human beings I doubt
these things are fundamentally different
today than they were in the times of the
classics and yet the world is hugely
different today
you